we have an update on a highly publicized
incident on a New York City subway train
where a man was choked to death by
another passenger a grand jury has
indicted Marine veteran Daniel Penny who
put 30 year old Jordan Neely in a Choco
back in May Neely had a history of
mental illness and Penny says he was
defending himself and other passengers
Lincoln has a report which includes
disturbing video of the confrontation
thank you
this cell phone video shows Marine
veteran Daniel Penny holding Jordan
Neely in a Chokehold prosecutors say
that's what killed him in a statement
attorneys for Neely's family called the
indictment the right result for the
wrong Penny committed CBS News legal
analyst Jessica Levinson I think what
the grand jury looked at in terms of the
evidence is evidence that led them to
believe a prosecutor could prove that
Penny used unreasonable Force were the
actions Justified given the potential
threat to others on that train Penny's
lawyers said their client restrained
Jordan Neely when Neely was threatening
to kill Subway Riders the three main
threats that he repeated over and over
was I'm gonna kill you I'm prepared to
go to jail for life and I'm willing to
die earlier this week Penny attempted to
defend his end his actions in his series
of video statements and then some people
say that this was about race which is
absolutely ridiculous cell phone video
shows that Penny held nearly in a choke
hold for nearly three minutes according
to Neely's family attorneys Mr Penny
should have let go before Jordan died
there is no excuse for choking anyone
for that long this case is really going
to turn on should Penny have released
the choke hold earlier New York has a
duty to retreat Rule and so what the
jury will be looking at is whether or
not Penny could have done last
there's no word on when penny might now
be arraigned in the wake of the grand
jury's indictment if convicted of the
second degree manslaughter charge he
could face up to 15 years in prison the
story is so tough especially when you
look at Neely's history with mental
health illness he lost his mother as a
teenager that apparently was really a
trigger for him and slipped through the
crack Social Services knew about him but
lost track at Sea yeah there's a lot
that could have gone differently and if
it had gone differently we would not
have ended up with where we are today
and jury selection is going to matter a
lot here if you've got a lot of New York
City subway writers depending on their
experiences on the subway that's going
to color how they hear this information
and what they decide yeah you're right
about that song Thank You Elaine